how's it going red my name for you and
welcome back to some more happy as you
got pretty much updated here so we'll
decide with the cap on we love luck
funny funny funny funny oh honey oh it's
one of these
if this gets popular I will make part
two isn't that lovely
alright I'm just gonna chill rekka my
sexual mores no we're not gonna do that
oh I'm so sorry so did I grab your butt
did I grab your bra am i grabbing no I
did oh no I did let it go no [ __ ] that
would have been at big holy [ __ ] alright
alright I'm grabbing this not grabbing
and watch but or anything
alright doing the doing the hump the one
thing it's my thing it's what I do
hello a post a little hey fat lady what
are you doing crazy [ __ ] crazy oh no oh
no oh no dad hey shut up son what else
are they doing over there holy [ __ ] that
Donna's whoa look at this that's what I
call skills oh well hello I'm taking
over like other kegs alright it's not a
problem not a problem pretty good so far
pretty good oh no no no that's my happen
but god damn it just going really fast
really fast you are good I'm still alive
oh yeah yeah oh no there we go come on
yes [ __ ] made it no I'm not something
he's gonna rape me a dummy did we play
zombie attack
don't let that what don't let a dog
heart that mean no sense what is this
what is this don't tell me I can shoot
you don't know grab it oh let's do that
again what again
ah oh no what wave - alright alright
that's not a problem yah oh nice alright
wave three damn this is epic come on
come on brah hey Stace oh no I didn't
right oh no I'm shake it shake it shake
take a little more I can't shoot more
why is she doing she's having a vibrator
in their pocket or something
Oh step yeah die
Oh No alright let's kill it spray that
[ __ ] that's what she said not a problem
wave five bring it [ __ ] bring it that
all rate five I did it that was pretty
fun now this one that's pretty cool and
drivable super Buy I'm pretty sure I try
that one actually family guy I'm not
really good at that of course I'm
getting your sister hmm
I don't want to brag or anything so you
know glass riders alright alright said
dad just be careful Justin baby could
pass this Oh
let's see if you can pass this you
little [ __ ] yeah Oh
synchronized ears not even odd even a
synchronized dance you little [ __ ]
alright here we go very easy should not
be a problem easy average yeah yeah
medium not the problem hard just not my
penis but you oh no no no no what the
hell is that
ah son [ __ ]
god damn - tongue Annika that's Tonya
later what the hell is that what those
come from all right let's just do this
not a problem not a problem so far
average medium it was hard like we died
on there we go nutter got nothing my
[ __ ] [ __ ] I hate when it goes up in
my up come on yes
Oh No what the hell is that
let's bring all right lovely I made it
ninya kid that's not pretty fun you
can't get past me Segway got whoa what
the hell was that I will
oh [ __ ] easy I want to try that again
all right oh god damn it
that's bad a day during Vespa don't go
away from me all right
hi hell Nico dog came in don't know what
that means but I'm sure it's something
fancy be discreet Nico what the hell is
wait all right
oh they are making love in front of me
isn't that beautiful thing it's just the
cards of nature all right not a problem
so far back off you like that [ __ ] whoa
what happens if my back what the hell is
this it's gonna hate haters gonna hate
don't care about anything this is my new
style uses my new swag backup hahaha
it's going on what the [ __ ] is this no
no wait
all this benches are mine what that's
what's happened here seriously what the
[ __ ] oh there we go alright
not a problem and I grab the girls what
that was shark what was that
alright that was pretty cool uh neon jet
fall Jimmy just Falls are usually pretty
epic so let's try this not a problem
if I could just Vespa that's fine let me
go I don't know you love it there we go
and know you love me woah oh I'm a
giraffe look that always wanted to be
one isn't this fantastic and well no
much it took my head give me back my
head I'm coming for that da-da-da-da-da
Hey it took my own son of a [ __ ] I mean
I can still make it
let's go son okay hey hey how's it going
here oh that's my arm just tickling
myself alright alright that's rest of my
body isn't that lovely
TV stars remake
compel that good luck and had dad please
don't do that so get that breakup I want
to watch TV later that makes no [ __ ]
sense you kept happening the TV's gives
happening all right not a problem all
right
I actually made it Holly [ __ ] let me but
what the [ __ ] all right not bad not bad
at all
oh no I moved the demolition time that
sounds fun tell is this mine a box son
did you do this [ __ ] whoa
what the hell is going on here
oh my dream has finally come true I'm a
box ah yeah that's so happy yeah [ __ ]
everything up a balk [ __ ] all of you
glasses
you can't just [ __ ] on me I'm a block a
little [ __ ] [ __ ] everything haters
gonna hate haters gonna hate
they see me rollin they hatin patrolling
and trying to catch me riding boxes
tryin to catch me ridin boxes trying to
catch me riding boxes then to catch me
ride in riding boxes first in my class
remember G drop skills on my chatting
and Yugi all right I don't know any more
of the lyrics but [ __ ] on giving the
cars can just go [ __ ] themselves because
I am a box I don't even know what that
thing is that part of my leg
- don't care I'm a box now I don't need
you I'm a [ __ ] guy there we go
why is it called demolition time if your
[ __ ] box will hard harpoon child and
challening Sheldon hard hard hard boon
just hard harpoon sounds wrong but he
managed to misspell challenge too so
that's awesome
can you make it can you cross this line
alright I'm pretty sure like your dad
hey guys I love you I just want to say
I'm sorry I'm a [ __ ] with this mom -
haha there are not bike ah bike made it
at least look at my leg I'm doing it dad
please don't do this
we can be together Oh God
I can't do anything synchronized and
yeah synchronized it shut up about
synchronized dance [ __ ] I'd kick your
village little [ __ ] what did you call me
here I got [ __ ] in a [ __ ] eh ah once I
get to you how to kill you I will I will
[ __ ] you up [ __ ] come here don't go
closer I will kill you
okay I'm sorry gosh oh and we all know
what the hell is he doing
alright go sad no no go sad
that [ __ ] oh no son of a [ __ ] I hate
ya ya you are the chosen one it was
supposed to bring college student what
whoa whoa by committed at least
well done bike well done where did son
go that is it's okay dad I'm a painting
now it's okay alright come on son
go son of a [ __ ] hey became a painting
again it's and dad and Emily I will
volunteer for alright
hey how do I make that hello how the
hell did I make that seriously what the
[ __ ]
we're together for at look at the legs
the legs are still moving isn't that
lovely
how the hell did I hey that I want to
watch a replay all right yes that is
clearly a victory right there all right
upward arrow Romney's an ad a fantastic
thing tip don't get hit
all right Jamie Levin whoa whoa no ah
son of a [ __ ] it's all your fault
pitiful right in my face oh no I'm pew
blood is coming out of my penis can
can't damnit what'd I tell you about it
look I have two arrows in my deck does
it look like I'm bleeding
no dad would stop doing good you look at
Percy bleeding dick I just say well
front left Oh No
how did this happen I'm still gonna make
it I don't know I probably can't stop
with this bat Oh doc I made it what the
hell is it
I am said moving Torah all this just
wanted to be a flexible toy so that's
what the hell the head is there - all
right dad I can show you what's going on
and it's nothing a Matar zarnow an
indian toy shop with arrows on it if we
can actually make this
side of a bet hi god dammit I like to
help I am a rope right now rope heaven
Yeah right - huh I actually like it
biggest are Megan Fox good dammit what
all right front left gotta make it last
thing I ever do
and nobody dies so easily god damn it oh
no oh yes
Oh fly Superman yes yes have it I made
it
make it pass right
holy [ __ ] I'm sorry dad it's okay
nothing's going on here sup well how you
doing
you want to go on a date later that's
totally cool I mean I do I should go to
a hospital no no I should I go it's not
not a problem
Jesse now relaxing and swinging my style
this is my swag my new swag is totally
to have the help all right um save the
lady alright let's try that one
don't move or I will kill her throw the
axe at the killed man and not the lady
all right girl I'm saving yo yes now
let's go and make a lab come here I'm
just kidding West by making love to you
instead oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah I like
that
yes rub magnetics what the hell is he
doing see are you jacking off no I'm not
jerking off I'm just pumping this sword
alright continue alright vespa come here
come here
ah let me suck you let me suck you what
what the hell are you doing don't you
want to [ __ ] me no I'm busy busy Vespa
oh yeah
okay I'm sorry let's try that again see
if I can do it double time
watch ha save the girl
ah oh whoops all right that just means
it's doing me Vespa command hyah man let
me let me love you tonight
and I'll make you feel all right I do
anything I want to be with you let me I
think I could out here so like I'm
pretty sure you and your subscribe to
come about today and I'll see you next
happy wheels or whatever it be do I mean
Allen
you